I hate school
Aaron many of us go through a phase of
hating school in general you'll hate
school because I'm looking at you you're
living at a time where you feel like you
don't fit in and that this time will
pass I know everybody tells you that but
it's true and it's also possible that
you have a teacher that you're not crazy
about and so you'll get through this now
if it's algebra I'm looking at you
estimating how old you are the thing
about math and algebra trigonometry is
you have to practice there's just no way
around it you have to do it over and
over and you might be picking school
because just to be rebellious we all go
through a rebellious phase but I
guarantee you if you learn algebra you
will be able to think abstractly not
just about numbers but about all sorts
of things and this will benefit you
greatly in life it looks like you're
sitting in a lab looks like you're
sitting in a laboratory setting there
it's like a biology class there's
nothing cooler than biology so you have
to in biology you have to memorize
things because biologists by long
tradition just make up words they're
crazy for making up words
who doesn't love reverse transcriptase
who doesn't love a Golgi body okay and
so on there's some memorization involved
and written de reticulum I'm sorry man
you just got to memorize some words but
it's worth it and you will fit in better
as the years go on carry on men
you